Let's now take a look at what happens when hundreds,
thousands,
and millions of people make decisions that have medical consequences and those
add up to have impacted the level of the entire population.
This exposes the issue of morality and the way that individual behavior impacts
public.
Good.
Okay.
We'll explore that with the examples of vaccination and antibiotic therapy.
However,
to begin with,
let's look first at medical intervention.
In human evolution,
physicians normally focus on individual patients,
whereas epidemiologists,
public health workers and evolutionary biologists focus on populations.
Yeah.
The chain of causes that links individual decisions by physicians to population
level consequences is real and it is not sufficiently appreciated.
Okay.
Medical decisions are now driving human evolution.
It's a striking case of cultural intervention in a biological process.
This is a nexus where we encounter the issue of individual where welfare in
conflict with group welfare,
that welfare of individuals comes into conflict with the welfare of groups when
the costs of private decisions are externalized and when public goods are
exploited by private interests.
Those are really two ways of saying the same thing.
Yeah.
In the medical arena.
Such conflicts have moral as well as economic dimensions.
The
probably best way to introduce this is the debate in the United States over how
to finance health care.
It exemplifies the complexities of these conflicts.
Yeah.
A single payer plan,
we're almost participate provides the greatest coverage at the lowest cost to
the society as a whole.
Yeah.
But such plans do not give individuals the freedom to decide whether they want
to be insured at all and if so,
by whom?
Yeah.
From the point of view of the population,
someone who does not join is a cheater parasitizing a public good who is
increasing the cost of health care from the point of view of a young healthy
person.
That decision is justified by short term self interest.
Yeah.
Such conflicts of money and values arise repeatedly at the intersection of
individuals and populations.
We can see them quite well in the problem of vaccination and herd immunity,
the great vaccine sterilized,
so measles,
mumps,
rubella,
pertussis,
diphtheria,
smallpox,
TB,
polio.
Those are all vaccines that sterilize the population and do not allow the
pathogen to replicate in any vaccinated individual.
They protect people for life.
They removed them from the pool of susceptibles who might be able to transmit
the disease.
When the proportion of immune people is high enough,
that figure is about 90% for measles.
The disease can no longer spread and the population is protected by herd
immunity.
So in that case,
even those who are not vaccinated are protected.
They're protected by the high frequency of people who are vaccinated.
Herd immunity is a public good created by those who have been vaccinated that
protects those who decide not to be vaccinated.
That leads us to raise this question is refusal to have your child vaccinated a
crime when enough people refuse vaccination,
the disease can break out and those who suffer and sometimes die or usually the
youngest.
For example,
in the California pertussis outbreak in 2010 all of the deaths occurred in
infants who were less than three months old.
The young and the innocent.
The false claim that measles vaccination causes autism caused immunization rates
to drop.
Measles,
which can be deadly,
has broken out several times and children have died as a result of this
reaction.
Are those who promote such false hoods indirectly guilty of murder or perhaps of
manslaughter?
Do we need laws that address crimes committed against populations rather than
individuals or legal system is not particularly well constructed to deal with
this?
Another issue that arises is that of imperfect vaccines and pathogen virulence
imperfect vaccines can drive the evolution of increased very lynch and target
pathogen by allowing patients to survive longer and by giving more virulent
strains,
more time to transmit.
This has been confirmed in Meissen and chickens
vaccinated individuals benefit,
but the indirect costs have increased.
Very Lens is externalized to the whole population.
Individuals in which the vaccine is ineffective and those who have not yet been
vaccinated are then exposed to pathogens that have higher virulence.
The HPV vaccine and all Kennedy Malaria vaccines are imperfect.
They do not sterilize.
We should still vaccinate.
There's no question about that.
Even with imperfect vaccines because many,
many lives will be saved,
but we should also be aware of the consequences and prepare for them.
Another place where the conflict between individual interest in group interest
is striking concerns.
Antibiotic therapy,
antibiotic therapy benefits the individual patient who does incur some costs for
because of local resistance evolution.
That means in the in that own patient's body,
but most of the cost is externalized.
In diffuse,
it's borne by the population as a whole.
Agricultural use of antibiotics has a similar kind of logical structure.
The individual farmer benefits and the cost of resistance is externalized.
That's not something that the farm usually sees himself.
The externalized cost is the global spread of resistance and that is something
to which millions of individuals decisions have contributed
those externalized costs of accumulated and they now pose mortal threats to
millions of patients.
The health of everyone on the planet is now directly or indirectly threatened by
the spread of antibiotic resistance,
so there are three lessons from this.
The first is that the conflict between individual and group interest is real.
It's not going away.
It can be mitigated but not eliminated.
The second is that medicine and public health have changed the human environment
radically and are now major drivers of natural selection on traits of medical
importance.
And the third is that sometimes when medicine solves old problems,
it creates new ones.
To summarize,
private decisions about medical treatment accumulate to have serious public
consequences.
The exhibit bounded rationality,
they seem to make sense,
but they are ultimately irrational at both individual and population levels.
We need an open conversation about the health consequences of the tensions
between individual liberty and social responsibility.